lens for carrying out assignments on
excellent performance
thank you okay so i think we should
begin now
and others may join in the y
so i welcome you all for today's webinar
on bioinformatics for precision medicine
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand and diagnose and treat
major life-threatening diseases the
transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data
that is being collected from patients
animal models
and last large scale cell line
experiments
in this program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed
and integrated to study the basic
biology associated with
viruses and their hosts cancer onset and
development and outcomes as well
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for
daily interaction with thousands of
users
that are a part of a bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech before we start
with the
talk i would want to introduce us we are
a us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration
between buying biotech and numerous
academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in
five different regions with over 10 000
users around the world
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world this online program
includes weekly sessions with an
instructor
online tracking and review of student
progress access to all the resources and
materials online
for self-paced learning access to expert
guidance in problem solving educational
and research pipelines
and domain data analysis on our big data
server for 15 days
let me introduce you to the program
mentors dr hart preeth has an expertise
in the application
of statistical machine learning
techniques and biomedical data and the
development of prediction tools and
databases
and looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar who is an experienced
buying fermentation with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industrial
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omixlogic training and
research fellowship
dr jeffuliano chavez post-doctoral
fellow at university of chicago
he is killed in bioinformatics and an
expert in glioblastoma
now to speak about the program and why
bioinformatics is a critical component
of precision medicine
let me pass it on to ceo pinebiotic ilya
brodsky over
thank you everyone thank you so much for
the introduction
and i wanted today to speak briefly
about why bioinformatics for precision
medicine
why it's such an important topic and how
can you get
acquainted with some of the important
challenges that are yet to be solved
and the methods that could be used to
address some of those questions
so before i begin i wanted to mention
that
our company is a technology transfer
company that
originated at the tower bioinformatics
research center
it's a research center from university
of haifa in israel
and what we have done is we have taken
the innovation that
they have assembled together in an
online computational platform
and packaged it with additional training
resources and project examples
and this has been a work of our team
so not only myself but people that are
highly
experienced in these domains including
bioinformatics
training content delivery and things
like that and so as a result
what we've really built i think is a
community
uh that is beyond just the training
and uh the goal of omixlogic programs is
actually to provide
the training in bioinformatics but it is
to enable independent research that is
guided by
experts in peer example and this growing
community
i think shares the passion for
data-driven research and an appreciation
of citizen science and
what that means really is that all of us
can ask
questions all of us can have hypotheses
what i think unites us is our
appreciation for
data and evidence that we can find in
that data
and therefore we appreciate the skills
that are needed to be able to ask those
questions
and get those answers correctly and so
as a result i think that these programs
are enabling
thousands of students around the world
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data sciences
and so that's why we don't um think that
we've figured everything out and so we
continue to build our network of mentors
and contributors to the program and
that's why it's important for us to
maintain this growing community and we
have two social media groups
and maybe someone naked you could paste
the links to our
linkedin group and to our facebook group
so we have a group on linkedin called
omixlogic and it's dedicated to machine
learning biomedical data
mining and high throughput data analysis
and also
a big data analysis group of over 2000
members
on facebook so please join us there
connect with us and connect with our
mentors if you are a mentor or you want
to be a mentor
please join and let us know if you would
like to be
a contributor in some way please also
reach out to us directly
so let me start first by uh highlighting
some of the things that probably many of
us already know
for example cancer which is one of the
leading causes of morbidity and
mortality worldwide
is much more prevalent in areas of the
western world
that has a growing and older population
and so if you think about that trend of
the population becoming older
and having additional comorbidities
it is clear that to address this
effectively
the same standard measures that are
working for everyone
are not going to work for any particular
individual
in a very precise and effective way
and so it's very important for us to
recognize this trend
and to understand what are some of the
ways that we could effectively address
this growing problem
that is going to require much much more
investment
in new technologies to address these
pressing needs for example
when we think about cancer we need to
understand
what are the drivers of cancer
progression what are the risks
associated with developing cancer
and therefore develop screening and
early diagnostic
tools to develop what are to
develop an understanding of what are the
markers of cancer risk and progression
and so in that kind of approach what
we're really seeking to understand
is how can we detect these molecular
signatures
that are very uh specific and unique
to each individual and be able to
recognize
that small piece of data that signal
out of noisy huge data sets that are
generated every day for millions of
patients around the world
and what that has to do with are new
technologies that
allow us to look directly into the dna
understand the genes and rna
transcription and
look at the sequences of individual
cells and tissues
as this disease develops over time
and so what we're looking at is really a
collection
of complex data sets that include
patient-derived cell lines
patient-derived xenograft models or
animal models
with human tumors in them so the cell
lines and the
patient derived xenograft models are
some examples of how we can study the
basic biology behind this disease
but also we can incorporate the clinical
trials
and some of the big data collected from
real patients
where we can find some signature
information
and start to ask questions and
eventually what we're seeing
as a result of that is more precise
and targeted therapy for many diseases
including cancer therapy and a lot of
these are actually
changing our ability to treat people
more effectively
based on these molecular signatures
combining our understanding
of drug metabolism with our
understanding with genetic
predisposition
and with an appreciation of disease
progression or the basic biology behind
how this disease goes from non-malignant
to more and more malignant and invasive
and eventually metastatic cancers
that ultimately lead to death and so
this appreciation of
data really is central to our ability to
be able to provide
more effective and precise treatment of
patients
now unfortunately what that brings us to
are some big
challenges with data that is very
diverse
very different because it was generated
by
thousands of labs around the world
different hands
different methods and approaches it was
generated from many different types of
people we don't know all the information
about those people
so really it's a problem of big data and
this problem of big data
is a different type of a challenge than
what clinicians
and biologists are used to so
biologists coming from a life science
background are used to
clean data experimental data data that
had a design
data that had very specific parameters
included in how the data was generated
and therefore you can test your
hypothesis
by looking at the signal in that data
and for clinicians i think it's even
much more challenging than that because
what they're used to be
dealing with is data that is not high
throughput it is
data that is obtained from lab reports
those lab reports come with a medical
history with a medical background
and are contextualized by medical
knowledge
that that individual or that location
really has
and so as opposed to that when we come
to this
challenge of big data in the clinical
application
we need to appreciate some things that
are coming really from the research side
as well as understand the context
for many different patients that we
could potentially not
ever interact with but they're really
repositories of raw data
that we can mine and extract some
meaningful signatures from and
potentially that could help us answer
some important
questions about the patients that we
interact with and so
at the baseline of this i think is
one of these technologies and this
technology is called next generation
sequencing
and i think that for many of you
probably you've heard a lot about
genomic
data you've probably heard about the
applications of genomic medicine
in a variety of different diseases but i
think what is important is for everyone
to
have that skill set and have that
expertise
in being able to look at the data
understand its quality be able to
find specific signal and then to also
lead to biological or even
clinical interpretation of that signal
and that's really what this program is
going to be about
so we're going to introduce you to a
number of different ways to study this
kind of data
analyze sample projects that we've
prepared and curated
for you to understand the specific
questions and the applications of that
data set
and then introduce you to some of the
methodologies that will be useful for
you to
practically work with such data sets
understanding
genomic variants understanding gene
expression
and the variation in gene expression
based on differential
gene expression looking at the
annotation
and interpretation of how these
differentially expressed genes could be
combined
into specific biological pathways and
how can we really understand the
biological pathways
in the context of a particular disease
or a biomedical question and so one of
the repositories that we will turn to
is what's called the cancer genome atlas
or tcga
now tcga is a very important
repository of thousands of samples
collected from patients that
are uh that have many different types of
cancer so coming from different tissue
and and buying sites and what it
provides us
is some kind of an appreciation for
multi-omics data
and its role in understanding the
disease stratification so how is disease
uh variable between different patients
patient stratification how different
patients
are represented in this data set they
come from different ethnic backgrounds
different age groups different
sexes genders and how can we
use this data to understand the disease
in a much more precise way so this is a
really unique repository that
actually anyone can gain access to and
start downloading that data to be able
to ask
research questions finding associations
between
treatments between risks between
different types of omics data and so
what we will address in this program is
how to
integrate such data to be able to find
patterns
that are relevant to different types of
cancers
we'll also take a look at some of the
algorithmic approaches
that allow us to apply machine learning
to extract signal from
data sets that were generated in a high
throughput way
and so one unique aspect of high
throughput
high throughput experiments is that the
data has been generated in an automated
way
and we can generate such data from cell
lines
based on for example response to
treatment so ultimately the goal there
is not to understand the molecular
mechanisms behind
efficacy of drug treatment for example
but it's really to find associations to
understand some signal some kind of
biomarker
of efficacy and that kind of information
can then help us assign better
treatments to patients
not by understanding and studying each
patient individually
but actually running some algorithms
that could bring out that information in
front of the
in front of the person who is delivering
the treatment
and guiding them in their decision
making so there we will take a look at
how actually both of these are
integrated so we'll take a look at
animal model experiments cell line
experiments and then compare them
to the variability in patients looking
at
research articles that describe the data
sets
and trying to extract signal that is
aligned between cell lines animal models
and
ultimately addresses the challenges with
individual patients
now in addition to cancer many other
diseases
are going to be on everyone's mind
obviously we live in an era of a
pandemic and so it's important to
appreciate
the role that viruses play
not only in the pandemic that we're
experiencing right now
but also in many other conditions so a
lot of times we think of infectious
diseases like source growth ii
as a virus that is causing a pandemic
but
surprisingly many different viruses are
involved in a variety of diseases for
example
abstain bar virus is involved in many
cancers
hepatitis can lead to liver cancer so
there's many uh
diseases including neurological diseases
that could be associated with either the
direct
effect of the infection or inflammation
that is caused by chronic infection and
so we'll take a look at how
other types of diseases could also be
studied using technologies like next
generation sequencing
to understand the disease itself the
immunology or the host response to that
disease
and the variability in disease
manifestation
in many different types of patients
because of
what is actually going on in different
tissues and cells that we
look at through the lens of data and so
that's why
i think that bioinformatics is really
central to our ability to improve
medicine
and improve treatment that is more
effective
less toxic and guided by our
understanding of these molecular
signatures
and so to develop bioinformatics skills
you need to have some sense of the
biology
computer science and the statistical
methods that are used to analyze such
data
and so we hope that as a result of this
program what you will be able to gain
is an understanding of a variety of
bioinformatics algorithms and software
to appreciate the different databases of
data
that includes genomic data from cancer
studies infectious disease studies and
other diseases
you will appreciate the analytical
techniques
and approaches that are needed to
analyze data and you will be exposed to
a variety of data science skills that
if you are interested in you can pursue
further in other types of training
to develop a practical skill set that is
needed
for the age of big data and so as an
example
we have here a few omics data and
infectious disease research that i think
will also cover
in many of the sessions that we'll
discuss that will include
an overview of viral genomics and
evolution immune response biomarkers as
well as an
overview of microbiome and its role in
infection
now obviously a lot of what i'm saying
seems like
too much to cover in a single program
and so that's why
what our team has done is collected a
number of program resources
that we're going to be making available
to all of the program participants
to make this a more streamlined and
effective use of your valuable time
so we will not only cover these live
sessions like we're
doing today we're also going to provide
you access to our training materials
fast big data analysis tools that you
can run
via a visual graphic user interface
curated project data sets so you don't
have to spend all of your time
finding data but you will be given some
data sets that you can quickly go
through to understand
the point and the connection between the
analysis and the biological
relevance as well as these interactive
sessions
that will be guided by mentors that i
will introduce in just a couple more
minutes
but before i do that i want to introduce
you i know that some of you are probably
already familiar with this but i'm going
to briefly speak about our big data
analysis platform
that allows anyone to quickly go through
some of the important methods in
bioinformatics
and try them out on different types of
projects
so we will in a second go into
how to register and how to create an
account and
once you do we will take a look at this
big data analysis platform
so that you can understand that you can
both learn and then
use this platform for actual research
projects that you might have
and so here you will find a variety of
different types of omics data that you
can analyze
you can run demo pipelines to understand
the logic behind
some of the different analyses that we
will use you will also see how you can
share your analysis with someone else
so that someone like a mentor can
provide you with technical information
about what went wrong
in your analysis and it also includes
user-friendly tools to apply
data mining and annotation of biological
information so that you can get
quick insights about the data sets
you're analyzing
so to really see how all of this works
let's go to learn dot logic
and let's start by creating an account
and that will allow us to take a look
at some of the data sets and some of the
example or projects that we will cover
in the program
okay so uh to go there uh sonica if you
could please
share the link
okay so when you get to this program
uh sorry when you get to this portal
learn omixlogic.com
uh you can create a free login
this login is going to be uh free for
anyone you don't have to participate in
the program in fact if you would like to
use this
asynchronously you can okay when i share
my screen let me stop sharing just real
quick
um so when you create your account
you will gain access to both the
coursework
and the um both the coursework
and the platform
okay so here you can see that you can
create an account
for free those of you that don't have an
account you can do that now
i'm just going to sign in
and once you're in i will show you what
are some of the resources that we will
be using and later on i will pass it on
to somalika
to also look at how to register for the
program itself
okay so please let me know once you're
in
and once you have an account you can
put yes or number one or something like
that in the chat box so that we know to
proceed
okay so i see people signing up right
now
so if you have not signed up yet please
sign up i want to
demonstrate how the program resources
are going to work
okay thank you david
all right thank you dr beshear
okay so hopefully you've created your
account now
you will find that your account comes
with a personal profile
and in this profile the first thing that
you want to do is you want to
finalize your name your profile picture
give it some description about you and
this is going to become your
personalized
center of your learning experience so
here you will find
the courses that you are taking your
progress
if you've completed some course you will
see a certificate
you will also see your certificate
separately here if you would like to
download them
but importantly you're also going to
have these programs here
and so once you join one of the programs
again you will see
what are the specific uh things that are
associated with each one of our programs
so if you go to the programs tab
here here you will find all of the
upcoming programs that we have
and in this particular programs on
precision medicine
we have included a number of courses and
projects
that are going to be relevant for your
ability to learn
and apply bioinformatics techniques to a
variety of
questions and examples so here you will
find projects like
the cancer genome atlas an example with
liver cancer project
you will see some projects on cobit 19
you will see some technical skills that
are going to be useful
as you learn to integrate visualize and
analyze your data
and you will see a number of
explanations about some
important machine learning techniques
that we will cover in the course as well
so take a look at this and later on
sonorico will explain
exactly how this program is organized
to continue and pass it on
the main component i think that
differentiates this program from some of
the
other programs that you will find online
on similar topics is that this is not
just access to these online resources
this is access to training material
big data processing which you will
typically not find
in anywhere else and this is going to
give you some
real uh examples of
methods to process your data and so to
briefly
introduce this resource all of you that
have an account
you can use the same account to access
a demo pipeline that i will briefly
demonstrate
to show you how easy you can go from
learning about
a specific method of analysis to
actually using that method of analysis
and so to do that i will go under the
transcriptomics section
and i will open a number of demo
projects that we will use
during this program so one of them is
called the cell line project and so this
is a project where they took
a variety of cancer of breast cancer
cell lines
and performed gene expression analysis
so they generated
transcriptomic data to understand
what differentiates between different
types of breast cancers
so here we can quickly process the same
data
and as we go through the analysis
appreciate
what are some of the logical steps that
you need to take
to go from raw next generation
sequencing data fast q files
all the way to getting a table of
expression so the main
steps are pre-processing mapping and
then
quantification of expression levels and
what i'll do today is i'll build a very
simple pipeline
that in reality if you were to try and
make this pipeline on your own
might take you maybe a few hours a few
days or even a few weeks depending on
your level of expertise but you'll see
how quick and simple this could be right
here
so first of all what we'll do is we'll
clean up those raw reads
and we'll make sure that we remove the
technical adapters
from library preparation we will then
address the
issue of pcr amplification that could
bring in some technical variation that
we don't want to confuse with biological
simple
signal then we will align these reads to
the reference genome using both type 2
and then we will quantify the levels of
expression
to get a table of fptm gene expression
using our sent once we've completed this
pipeline
i can click on end and i will take a
look at some of the output data
so it's a real quick process to go from
having that raw data to then analyzing
that data and you
saw some of the variations into the
pipeline that you can make
as you go through and then get getting a
result
so that you can appreciate the inputs
and the outputs very quickly
once you get those results importantly
we have
all kinds of additional methods to mine
this data visualize this data
and even integrate multi-omics data to
quickly understand the relationship
between
gene expression genomic variants
maybe microrna and long non-coding rna
as well as some clinical information
given it is structured in the proper way
so we will go through all of these tools
but another thing that i want to mention
about this program is that
it is the resources and the live
sessions
and big data analysis tools and curated
data sets
but another major component are really
the experts that come to the program to
provide you with
mentoring so if you're a researcher or
even a student
or a citizen scientist and you want to
develop a research project one of the
challenges that you're going to face
is really getting the knowledge that you
need quickly
to select a project identify a data set
translate your idea into a technical
requirement that you can execute on
and there are many many challenges along
the way and so instead of learning from
your own mistakes and trying to do this
by trial and error
it is always beneficial to turn to
someone that has gone through the
process that you are looking at
and leverage their expertise to make
your project
more uh more effective and more
ambitious perhaps than what you would be
able to achieve on your own
and so to briefly introduce our mentors
we have a collection of mentors that
we've been
building a network with and and we want
to give them opportunities to
share their expertise and their
experience and so
uh briefly i want to introduce uh
depogiano javas
who is a postdoctoral researcher
at university of chicago and
deals with glioblastoma so depaliano
over to you
hello everybody good morning i apologize
because i am in the lab and i
it's still mandatory to use a mask over
here
as elia was saying i'm a postdoctoral
scholar here at the university of
chicago
i work with neuroblastoma actually
it's a type of cancer derived
from the formation of the central
nervous system in
kids it's a pediatric cancer
i will share some a couple of slides
with you
so that you can get a better sense of
the
types of answers that we can study
with bioinformatics so i
chose a title for this towards a better
classification of neuroblastoma tumors
so as elia was saying we can use a broad
variety of
data types to analyze tumors
i also have other projects where i deal
with
infectious diseases but today i decided
to talk to you about
neuroblastoma because i think in general
people are really interested in
cancer also this is a pediatric cancer
so i think it's really appealing
to think about ways in which we can help
kids grow more more healthy
and safer so the problem
uh with neuroblastoma you can think from
this perspective
so the tumor is formed basically of a
heterogeneous mass
of cells and i want to highlight to you
that there are two major cell types in
neuroblastoma tumor these two major
types are the adrenergic type
which seems like
a neuron so you can see these
projections in this in the cell
cytoplasm here
and that's what gives them the
characteristic of a neuron and remember
that i said the neuroblastoma is derived
from the development
of the central nervous system the other
population that is
very important for neuroblastoma
development is the mesenchymal
population of cells
these cells are not differentiated
so when when i when i speak about the
neuroblastoma you can
sorry when i when i speak about an
adrenergic cell
and that it looks like a neuron you can
think of the concept that it's a
differentiated cell so compared to the
adrenergic cells the mesenchymal cells
are not differentiated
the mesenchymal cells are not
tumorogenic
in the sense that they do not grow as a
tumor but the problem is that these
cells they can
differentiate into an adrenergic cell
and that
is the problem because although they are
not tumorogenic themselves they can
differentiate and become tumorogenic
mesenchymal cells are not sensitive to
chemotherapy so in fact after you give
chemotherapy to a child these cells are
going to survive and they're going to
cause the cancer to relapse because as i
said they're going to
they're they're likely going to
differentiate and
give rise or start disease progression
as an adrenergic cell so this leads to
the idea
in the field that these mesenchymal
cells are responsible
for a process called a concept called
the minimal residual disease concept
where
you give chemotherapy to the child you
kill
some of the adrenergic cells but
the mesenchymal cells they are not
killed by chemotherapy
they stay alive they can differentiate
into amazing
adrenergic cells and then therefore the
cancer relapse
relapses or disease the disease
progresses
as i said uh adrenergic cells are
homogenic
and they are sensitive to chemotherapy
there are many ways in which we can
classify these
adrenergic and mesenchymal cells or
rather adrenergic and mesenchymal tumors
and these are some of the technologies
that we use to classify
these cells and the tumors so
this paper is from 2017 and people used
rnac
so you can see this is a technique
called
a machine learning technique called
hierarchical clustering
so you can classify the mesenchymal
cells
and they are they're different than the
adrenergic cells so you can basically
segregate separate or cluster
the adrenergic mesenchymal cells you can
also
classify these cells using biochemistry
experiments this is a western blot it's
based on the interaction between
some of the proteins that are
characteristic of the adrenergic and
mesenchymal cells with
antibodies this is immunological method
this is a
another method that is based on scoring
you basically associate a number with a
mesenchymal
genetic characteristic so as i said this
is
using rna-seq data there are also
a different type of classification where
you use
other than rna-seq you use chromatin
immune precipitation sequencing
and that's based based on chromatin
accessibility
so these enhancer regions are regulatory
regions that interact
with the cellular machinery that is
responsible for the
expression of the the genes basically
the expression of the proteins
so it's really a uh this is
at the level of epigenetics not genetics
so this is a level
above genetics because it's
it is thought that the epigenetical
epigenetic level of pacification
is happens before the actual gene
expression
as i it's illustrated here on the right
part
these um these chromatin immune
precipitation peaks
they can also be used to classify
the mesenchymal cells and the adrenergic
cells
one thing that is really interested
interesting
about the these epigenetic methods is
that they can just be used
as i showed with the rna-seq and this is
a
principal component analysis showing the
separation or the
clusterization of these again these
adrenergic indesign
cells but here not using gene expression
uh here it's using the super enhancer
regions the
the data that comes from the chromatin
immune precipitation
so really what is established
nowadays is that you can separate
basically the group of kids that have
neuroblastoma into two
basic groups that are
the high risk group and
the non-high risk group so as you can
see in the survival curve
the group of kids that are classified as
a
high risk they have a very lower
significa probability of survival
compared
to the group of kids they are classified
as non-high risk
but once you classify the tumor of
a child as a high risk
tumor there is basically no way
that you can use to predict
the prognosis of that of that group of
that
of that tumor so in neuroblastoma
after again after a child is classified
as having a high risk tumor you cannot
predict
how that tumor is going to act whether
it's going to
progress malignantly or whether it will
not
but one thing that gives us hope give us
some hope is the fact that the
mesenchymal cells
may provide some sort of prognostic
ability because as i said these are the
cells that survive
chemotherapy so if we are able to
detect these cells and the percentage
of these cells that are present in the
tumor
we think that we really have some sort
of prognostic
ability in uh for deciding
what to do about the treatment of a
child
so i'm going to finish now because this
is basically the
the the work that i'm doing right now
uh which is to use to develop these
mesenchymal scoring systems
uh to classify high risk tumors so we
we basically compare the uh
gene expression the epigenetic profile
profiles of the mesenchymal and
adrenergic
tumors and we then try to see if that
has
some uh prognostic value so i'll briefly
explain this to you because this is
really the
the the fundaments of the research that
i'm doing so this is in
uh i'm still working on this this is not
published yet
but what we can see what the our data
suggests
is that uh the mesenchymal scores in
fact
have a very uh good relationship or a
good association with low
survival probability and therefore
we think that this method can be used to
quantify the genetic profiles of these
kids
that are on the high risk group
and therefore we can test some
treatments and we can
propose that uh
we have ways to measure and to determine
whether
a high-risk tumor is going to have
a good or bad prognosis so i would like
to
end with that statement that
we think that we can find
ways to classify high-risk neuroblastoma
tumors
using these bioinformatic technologies
and the combination of dna sequencing
and uh
uh bioinformatics analysis
thank you very much for the invitation
thank you so much dr gippiliano
and now before i pass it on to dr mohair
to discuss the session details let's
quickly
uh have a poll launched to know you all
better so i've launched a poll and
i would be keeping it on for a minute
and let's
see what we get as answers my first
question is
what is your designation undergrad grad
post graduate faculty researcher
administration and what is your research
in trust data science bioinformatics
neuroscience precision medicine or
infectious diseases
thank you for your answers i would be
keeping the
uh pole on for uh 30 seconds
thank you all for answering dr mohit
over to you
thank you sunalika
okay thank you ilya and chipolliano for
this wonderful
uh talk about your project and also
about
bioinformatics for uh precision medicine
hello everyone my name is mohit mazumdar
and i'm one of the
co-project mentor of the program so
as uh as for today let us go through the
through the sessions that we are going
to have uh what actually they are
discussed and
what we have in the curriculum how that
aligns with
the subject and the importance of what
we discussed today
so let me let us go through the sessions
as one by one
one second
yeah so the first first session of the
program
will be on 6th july and it will start
with an overview of all the resources
that your
all the resources that we discussed and
also the access to the program
so for the first session uh this will
include program orientation
group discussion uh to learn from the
participants of the program and about
the
about the research interests and
objectives so the orientation is also
is to get you familiarized with uh the
introduction to bioinformatics
so followed by this uh the first session
which is a
scheduled session to which focuses on
the problem
of cancer so in this session we will
also discuss about the complexity of
cancer biology
and the typical challenges that you see
in diagnostics at uh
organ uh tissue or cellular level uh and
we will also discuss about molecular
factors that
that are involved in uh in tumor
development
that are there in uh infor basic and
both the basic and both
translational research in oncology so
in this study uh where we have also a
few examples like ilia said to all of
you that we have already prepared a few
examples so in in one of the examples
is a study where you can see on the
screen uh a patient derived cell line
and this uh in this xeno the xenograft
models are also used in another study
and we have also uh info i mean
data sets where we use clinical trials
uh information
that offers a collection of data to
understand and uh get
information about the diagnostics and
also
treatment of cancer in patients
so uh the next session after that which
would be the second session
in the second session we will talk about
the technology after getting an overview
of
cancer and how deadly it is and what are
the different
characteristics uh to understand uh a
cancer
cell uh um so in the second session it
will be more about the technology as i'm
saying uh so it would be about
understanding
how next generation sequencing works you
will learn about shotgun sequencing
reads
and then you'll learn about how to make
the data structured and then
you will learn about uh different
bioinformatics methods
that uses uh like processing uh where we
will be doing uh both germline and
somatic mutations
we'll look at um the analysis where we
will do mapping
detection uh variants you can see on the
screen and also
in this in this uh in the last part
so in the last part of the session we
will discuss about the interpretation so
how can you interpret this data
and along with this like you will have
access to the resources that explains
all of this so that you kind of get
familiarized with what is being covered
and have a chance to do it at your at uh
at your own pace
so anytime that you feel that you have
uh
you have time to go through the
resources these are online courses that
are available on the learn omix logic
portal
so in here i mean we have different
resources that it
starts from a very intro very basic
introduction and then
goes into different processing pipelines
and how data can be interpreted
and how you can structure that data that
could make sense because it's from
a large large number of uh you know it's
a big data
and then you're transforming into a very
meaningful data set
so in this in this study in this session
i mean we will learn about how genomics
is used
in biomedical drug discovery and how
genomics is used
in different other areas
in translational research so in the
third session
uh which will be uh on uh processing of
uh another type of sequencing data which
is uh the transcriptomics
data so in this uh session after
learning about the genomic processing
data and its application in biomedical
research
and precision medicine you will learn
how we can measure
uh functional proteins and uh
look at the mrna abundance and
understand accurately understand the
alternative splicing so
you saw examples of rna sequencing
before so going through this entire
process of rna sequencing doing the read
quality and pre-processing yourself
going and then mapping it to the
reference genome
and then understanding its role by
quantifying the genes
and also the transcripts and in the same
way after doing that you would want to
do the visual
visualization so i think
this entire process is also to let the
scientific community know of what you
have uh unders
what you have obtained from as a result
so
expressing that in a visual form and
getting the visualization is a scientif
is a very important part of our
scientific uh scientific things that we
do uh
every day so in that sense we will learn
about how you can correctly and
uh visualize uh the gene expression
uh information and also do pca uh to do
that
and also go go through annotation and
interpretation
so in this uh in this session we will be
going through the
the for example the processing pipelines
will prepare a full
pipeline and then go through different
type of analysis
that we do for uh gene expression uh
data
so the session after that uh what which
will be the fourth session
uh is on machine learning so you have
already learned about two
overview of two uh different
different technologies which is genomics
and transcriptomics and then
you would want to learn about how do you
you know do this
makes make sense of this data and do
this uh
to find out uh different patterns that
are lying within
a large number of other data sets also
so finding predictive modeling
or like understanding how this uh data
what this data uh have information
so this uh complex collection where this
is
a about the data and the complex
collection we are looking at
different types of characteristics we
are looking between
correlation between a clinical
manifestation of disease
molecular patterns and how we can define
it
using different statistical analysis
right so machine learning approach
allows computational
uh power that could be applied to these
challenges so
in this session uh we will use machine
learning and during this uh during this
time as i was saying that there will be
resources
allocated that will help you go through
and do this
uh on your own so you will also have
access to the
coding platform uh coding uh playground
which is there and learn
where you can write and you know do
scripting in python and r and uh these
also ex
they are also like tutorials that takes
you through this entire process
so you know you know how to apply r and
python
in your genomic or transcriptomics data
analysis
so uh yeah that would be an experience
and that
uh these those will be uh available
uh to you as uh the session goes on and
we will
cover many of those aspects in these
live sessions so after going through and
learning about how do you visualize and
how can you
um actually analyze uh from different
project examples that we have prepared
for you
uh the next thing is to go and do it
yourself like finding those
uh important uh repositories on and
finding
the data sets from those important
repositories like uh
sra jio ncbi in that that are there in
ncbi and you already already discussed
about
the tcga repository so this session will
be about those
different repositories that are there
and very important for
any bioinformatician to you know explore
and
understand how to extract uh the
information that you need
for your project so we will be
discussing in that respect
and about the i mean opportunity many of
us here do not even understand the
opportunity that is
related to training like this i mean why
we are doing this
why uh why we are saying that our
independent
research is now very much possible and
within
reach of everyone why why so it's it's
because
uh the availability of data and yes i
mean uh
that that kind of data is available so
uh and ncbi is such a good example of
that you can see that how many
data sets have been uh already deposited
and on the way it is growing rapidly
every day
so after learning about the data sets
and how to figure out and find data
we will again after the first phase i
think it would be
it would be five sessions and then after
the fifth session the sixth session
would be about next generation
sequencing where we will learn about uh
viral genomes
in the host transcriptome so uh here we
will also learn about oncolytic viruses
so that is one of the
um one of the
feature of learning through precision
medicine program
is to learn about different aspects of
transmissions from cancer and then these
different viruses so here we will also
learn about like how
they are involved in tumor development
how do you connect from biology to
cancer and then learn about inflammation
and tissue damage
here we will also learn about how can we
align annotate
and do you know
mapping so we will learn about viral
genomes
and we will also learn about uh
alignment to databases of
those uh you know viral genomes so
after learning about that so the second
phase in the
where we we are going to learn about uh
different aspects of
how can we interpret uh biological
uh data from for virology and infectious
diseases
so in the in this session on which is uh
session seventh
we will learn about multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny
so here we will learn about how can you
study uh
viral genomes for liver blood and
neural tissues and we will also learn to
prepare data and setting
setting up bioinformatics pipelines
where you will find uh
to do phylogenetic analysis and
multiple sequence alignment of these
genomes so i think um most of you are
familiar with
phylogenetic tree so phylogenetics uh
is a study phylogenetics in in the study
of phylogenetics you learn about the
lineages
between different uh different species
and how you can interpret
that so after
that so which is the seventh session so
this is spanned across
uh two sessions a week so i
i think it would be all right and we'll
be going through this uh
and you'll get enough time to complete
uh the assignments and also go through
some of the
some of the courses and materials and
data sets that we have prepared for you
so learning about that uh
then practicing so it's very important
aspect of this program
is to do the hands-on hands-on tutorials
and do the hands-on
practice yourself to gain the most of it
and become an expert right so to do that
uh you have to be more comfortable by
in the on the on the platform that you
will have access to during the
during the uh during the one month
program so
uh here we will learn about workflows
and pipelines in bioinformatics so we
have discussed already i've seen
a lot of uh pipelines and workflows
there like uh
algorithms that are um that are
in that are put together in a logical
manner right
so and that uh in that way
we have a technology that helps us to
find out and you know detect those
challenges and
find out uh critical important important
information
to design our prop uh to design our
research correctly
so this is a very important role that
plays in bioinformatics and here we will
learn about you know detecting
and mapping those two databases and we
will also learn about
how you can understand about uh how
genomic uh how genomics and genomes
are and the evolutionary time correlates
so this is
something that we have uh planned for
this session
and here we will also like uh go through
uh
some of the processes in this uh this is
another one of the example
this is a birth death uh
example of evolutionary study uh
so here uh you will also there are like
parameters that we will cover
that are there to understand this sort
of algorithm and
what are different algorithms to do this
and how they can
be applied for a problem so
about the problem um so now the next
session
is about the problem from infection
to pandemic from a viral adaptation
so here we will have an example about
the corona virus pandemic and we will do
uh take out sequences from ncbi virus
and we will do comparative studies where
we will compare
these four sequences uh genomic
sequences uh
full sequences and find out like how
they can correlate and how
they make sense in you know activation
of immune response
uh and then cytocoin storm which is
caused by valid replication
and uh also could relate to what is
happening
currently um everywhere
so as i said uh that uh you would be
able to do it
alongside with us so we will use um
the tibia info platform and where we
have sections uh
on on to do this uh which is virus
quasi species so we'll discuss this and
we'll tell you like how
this is done um in session nine
so in after session nine the last
session
where this entire uh story comes to
an conclusion where we are going to
learn about host pathogen interaction
so after applying and learning about all
of these
technologies and how they can be
done for different diseases sorry
here we are going to learn about what
are the strategies that we can apply to
you know overcome so we will talk about
vaccine design so how bioinformatics are
how you can consider data and then think
about vaccine design so you have a lot
of information
coming from big data you know about the
sequences you know about the gene
expression
now you have figured out that this is a
protein of my interest and i think
these are the possible sites and based
on
the mutations that i've seen in the
genomics these are
some of the places that we should target
uh and that
these are some of the epitope binding
sites so based on all that information
uh the important
uh thing is to go for uh
uh data-driven hypothesis and that
data-driven hypothesis
is something that we are going to uh
going to
discuss throughout the program so uh in
the session
um we will cover about uh some of the
structure
such structures how do you connect from
host response to viral replication and
then
implications of that to a cell organ and
tissue
so exploring different viral strategies
for exploitation of forced mechanism
machinery and the viral protein
production
so these are some of the topics and
sessions that
that are there for precision medicine
and i think one of the best
part of this is that we also will be
doing
uh giving and going through the courses
the course work which
actually uh is is pretty amazing and
that's what we have heard from all of
our
all of our participants so far so
after doing this and if you have any
confusion and if you think that
bioinformatics is difficult
because we are integrating so many
things we are integrating data
we are integrating algorithms we are
integrating complex machine learning
methods
it it sometimes gets like really thought
it thought it to be like sometimes it
gets really challenging
but we are here to help you out with
that because we have gone through this
entire process
over and over uh again and thought of
different strategies that actually works
so with that i would now
uh maybe pass it back to sunalika
and we'll be happy to take any question
and answer and if you have any questions
and uh maybe i can also look into the
zoom
yes dr muit we have a question do i need
to have a specific
background to take the course
uh yeah i think there is uh the programs
the way
that we have planned them uh starts from
the basics so as
as i told you that if you have a basic
background in biology
and if you have interest if you have
keen interest in doing this
and if you have uh something to do
something to do with research so i think
this is a program for you
because uh what we will be going through
is research-based training
and uh this will take you to what is
happening not just like you know what
what we have put together but
uh taking real examples like the
articles that have published now
so it's actually correlates a lot with
what is happening in the industry but
also what is happening in in a cat
current research in academia as well so
that's the opportunity that you have
and uh if you would want to know and
learn from the very basic
we also have the coursework to help you
with that and
along with that we have mentorship and
then we have also a research fellowship
program
so it's just not that you can you can do
everything in
all of this in one month i think that's
that's quite uh
quite a challenging thing to do but it's
a very good thing to start with
somewhere
start from somewhere and this is the
that sort of opportunity that takes you
to
all of the great topics that are there
for discussion in scientific community
today
and then uh choose and understand and
decide
that what is that that you would want to
contribute to
so these are some of the some of the
thoughts that i'll leave
leave you with so now uh sanadika if
anyone has any any other question i
would be happy to answer that
that as well thank you so much dr mohit
we have a question for the
doctor japoliano dr bashar asks is there
any mechanism to prevent the
differentiation of mes to adrn
yeah actually he answered me on the
private uh
message thank you for that okay okay
thanks so much
okay so if there are any more questions
you can post it
on uh this chat box
i'm just sharing my screen let me just
quickly take you through the
preregistration and the registration for
the program
so by the email you would have got this
pre-registration link and if you don't
have one
i would be sharing with you on the chat
box itself you can pre-register yourself
for the program here
now when i say pre-register it's just a
formality to be a part of the program so
that we get your
details and on this pre-registration
page you would be able to find all the
details which are associated with the
program
what all would be covered the session
details are mentioned as well
and also we have answered few of the
frequently asked questions
so you can just go through the
preregistration page
and find your answers also all these
session details will just
dr mohit explained are mentioned on the
pre-registration page
now as i told pre-registration is just
to fill out the form so that we get your
entry but to proceed ahead with your
registration
and your enrollment in the program you
need to proceed with the registration
program
page here is the link
once you proceed with this program page
you would have to click on start your
application
and you would get three levels beginner
intermediate and
advanced the the three levels they are
basically
uh based on the basis of the provisions
that
you would be getting for the program and
the provisions are mentioned here
very clearly you can go through each of
them and pick the
um level which suits your requirements
the best
and we also have opportunities for
people who are
who are looking for uh scholarships for
their research work
and those who are interested to get
scholarships they can mail me at
marketing at the rate pine dot bio
and i would be uh glad to help you out
with the scholarship
process for your research work and you
can also mail dr mohit
at mohit and the rape pine dot bio
and we would be happy to clear all your
queries
uh we have a question the tashary
monday last how frequently these
programs are offered
so uh deeptha shri if i'm pronouncing
her name right
we i have these uh programs on going
every month but yes different topics
so uh we had bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
then we had a machine learning that's
the ongoing one
we have chem informatics program as well
which is ongoing but yes uh we won't be
repeating them
so we for the the precision that the
precision medicine one it would be
starting on
july 6 and it would end on
5th of august and i hope that answers
your question
and asks i just begin with
bioinformatics
i notice that many by informations use
mac os
okay so first of all that's not an issue
at all uh
i am actually using windows right now so
what are the advantages of
mac os compared to linux or window dr
mohit would you like to answer this in
detail please
i mean i don't think that there's any
advantages per se to mac os
i just think that because it's based on
unix
you can run some linux right there from
the terminal and a lot of people
end up using it so i think that's the
main reason i don't think that you
should be thinking that
you know if you want to go into
bioinformatics you have to use a mac os
computer
it's just something of preference
yes exactly i believe the same so it
doesn't matter whatever system you have
and whatever specification you have
while talking about specification it
just reminded me that many of the
researchers
uh they are the the basic shortcoming in
their
research work is their specification
there are many people who are not
able to actually update their systems
and get the required specification
to complete their research work and
that's where our server chiba info
server comes
into play and helps out carry out
different sorts of
big data analysis all at once uh
and not giving uh any you know
a thing to your systems specification
yes okay so uh
i have explained all the registration
and the preregistration forms and
also the sessions i hope are well clear
to you if anyhow you want to go through
the
the syllabus once again in a detailed
manner we also have the
syllabus mentioned on the syllabus page
i am sharing the link with you as well
and let us know if you have any doubts
thank you so much for joining us with
the session today
it was really great to have you all with
us thank you everyone bye bye
hope to see you soon in the sessions
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much dr
chupanyana
thank you thank you so much have a great
day